hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast automated in vivo
efficacy assessment and preclinical lung
disease models presented by dr. Laura
Chaffetz chief scientific officer
Byam I'm Alexis Carlos of laberd's and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by laberd's and sponsored
by vayam for more information on our
sponsor please visit viacom now let's
get started before we begin I would like
to remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click on the send button well
answer as many questions as we have time
for at the end of the presentation if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the support
tab found at the top right of the
presentation window will report your
problem by clicking on the answer
question box located on the far left of
your screen this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credits I'd like to now introduce
our presenter dr. Laura Chaffetz Lori
with says more than 15 years of
experience with invivo animal studies as
VP of chief scientific officer at V ayam
she oversees the development of animal
models and draws upon her experiences as
a molecular and behavioral
neuroscientist to direct the application
of AIIMS digital metrics to the animal
models in past experiences Laura
utilized a broad spectrum of mouse
models including transgenic and
nutrition induced models of
neurodevelopmental disorders such as
autism schizophrenia
Rett syndrome and blank site Laura
received her PhD in neuroscience at
Stanford University in 2006 dr. Chaffetz
you may now begin your presentation
thank you so much and thank you for
joining me today I'll be talking about
the vayam platform and how it can be
used for automated in vivo assessment
and preclinical lung disease models but
before we get into the specifics I want
to talk a little bit more about the
broader context in which we're looking
at this platform so this is something
that many of you may be extremely
familiar with but the cost of drug
development is rising exponentially here
I'm showing you some data from the Tough
Center for the study of drug development
in which you can see that the average
preclinical and clinical expenditure of
drugs from the 1970s all the way up
until more recent 2010 time frame where
we've gone from somewhere around 300
million for the cost of the development
of one drug up to now it's estimated to
be something like 2.5 billion dollars
for one drug and part of that has to do
with overall clinical success rates
which are currently down to eleven point
three percent from 16.4% in 2005 and
many of those are due to lack of
clinical to clinical failures to either
to lack of drug safety or efficacy
together got to be associated with maybe
about 75% of the drug failures that
occur and so there's a real push for
understanding why clinical failures are
happening and how we can improve both
from a preclinical as well as from a
clinical standpoint the probability of
success so there's been a lot of work to
reduce the number of drug failures
looking at various reasons why drugs
fail and if potential areas of
improvement some of those specifically
in the preclinical field are looking at
improved target identification than
validation an area that we're very
focused on is improving clinical
translatable
can you create better preclinical models
which are more predictive of disease and
potentially whether or not a drug would
be effective in the clinic and can you
identify biomarkers that make better
translate to the clinic and a biomarker
can be anything from molecule to in this
case we're actually thinking about
digital metrics as being potential
biomarkers that could translate into the
clinic in another area that people are
focused right a bit on is precision
medicine so can you improve patient
selection and in this case looking at
animal models and understanding
potential genes and molecules that would
help you better predict whether or not a
human in the clinic would respond
positively or negatively based on
preclinical data so with that as a
backdrop today's webinar is really
around looking at one potential
biomarker in this case lung function and
can we better build models to predict
época see associated with drugs and/or
safety side effects associated with
drugs that could translate into the
clinic so with that I'd like to go to
our first poll question for those of you
who are conducting rodent respiratory
studies what are some of the biggest
challenges that you've faced please
check all that apply these might include
they're invasive procedures in which
perhaps you can only do a single
assessment your results may be
inaccurate or can inconclusive perhaps
there's a high mortality rate or maybe
you have data gaps or loss so you only
get a little bit of data here or there
not enough to make appropriate
assessments or other I'll give you just
a moment to respond to the survey
thank you so much for all your great
results so lung function in particular
is quite challenging to assess in mice a
lot of studies have been done in the
early 2000s 2010 timeframe to look at
various ways that you can assess lung
function basically in vivo and rodents
and here are just a few examples of
articles that were published [ __ ] talking
about the various challenges and how you
might potentially be able to assess lung
function or lung mechanics and there are
a couple of methods that researchers can
often use which I'll talk about in the
next slide but really as we'll see many
of them have have trade-offs that need
to be made this is part of what Pete
what has been termed by Bates and our
Berwyn as the phenotyping uncertainty
principle so it's the idea that you may
be able to get very accurate
measurements but in an animal that is in
a non natural state versus less precise
measurements and animals that is that is
in a more of a natural state so let's
look at those so the trade-off here is
between precision and the natural
environment so on the precise size side
we have the forced oscillation technique
using the Flex event
so here it's highly invasive a mouse or
a rat is intubated and then there's a
highly controlled system which in
essence pushes air into the animal and
there are measurements of flow and this
is often the terminal procedure although
there have been improvements in in the
ability to actually wake up and recover
animals from these but because the
animals are anesthetized they're in
generally at a very unnatural State and
so you may have abnormalities in in what
you're measuring just based on the fact
that they are anesthetized but as I said
you get very precise results and then on
the other side you have data collected
in the platysma graph so here an animal
is placed into a small chamber in which
you can measure changes and pressure
relative to you the outside world it's
non-invasive you can put the animals in
as many or as few times as you'd like to
to measure them over the course of a
study but the environment is very
uncontrolled and for those of you who
have ever worked with this you know that
an animal that is awake and moving
around you'll get results that are quite
different from an animal that is asleep
and breathing quite naturally and
therefore the results can often be
inconclusive so before we move to the
next slide I'd quickly like to ask for
one more survey question and this time
asking about the various methods that if
you are looking at lung function you use
so here the question is how do you
monitor lung function now do you use a
platysma graph do you use the forest
oscillation technique perhaps you may
use a video based system or it's too
challenging and so therefore you don't
monitor lung function in your studies
right now I'll give you just a few
moments to respond to this question
thank you so much for those great
results so what I want to introduce to
you is this idea that you can actually
potentially use automated an automated
homepage monitoring system to get better
results or better prediction of lung
function in a non-invasive freely moving
animal so all would all introduce the
biome system in just a second but as I
go through this presentation some of the
questions I'd like you to keep in mind
are are these results consistent and
most importantly do they recapitulate
something about the underlying biology
or pathology so one thing that we know
about using the pathenger graph or using
this the Flexi vent system is that these
often very nicely replicate what you can
see with biology or pathology so changes
in the lung function from those
measurements will highly correlate to
what you might see in changes in in the
loan so what is the biome system so
here's an overview of the platform the
biome system is a smart housing rack so
the biome system is a is comprised of a
rack with individual ventilated cages
above each of the individual ventilated
cages is a white box which you can see
in the center we call that the slab and
the slab contains video data HD video
cameras as well as gas pauses both in
and out so we can monitor temperature
and humidity at all times what I want to
book us today on however is our use of
the HD video camera to actually monitor
resting breathing rate and motion in the
animals 24/7 so to the very
you can see a viewpoint from the camera
looking down into the cage you can see
an animal off to the to the very left
upper left-hand corner there a black
animal sleeping underneath the food
hopper inside the cage we also have
running wheels seeing them the lower
left ladders seen across the upper
portion of the screen as well as water
in the lower course water in the lower
right hand corner of the cage as you can
see the cage is laid out in such a way
that there is no place that the animal
can get away from the camera so we've
got a good view of the animal 24/7 and
we can actually and what I'll show you
in just a second monitor breathing rates
and the animals as long as they're
resting so how do we do this so here's a
slide just giving you a high-level
overview of how we create our digital
metrics so in the upper left hand corner
you can see a video of a mouse two mice
in the cage and there are small green
dots overlaid across the video we
actually use complex computer algorithms
to compare the location of pixels from
one video image to the next we capture
24 frames per second and we look at the
vectors in terms of the location of that
pixel from one to the next to identify
vectors of motion and that's read out on
our motion metric those same changes we
look for oscillations and in the
spectrum of breathing rate
so between generally 60 and 600 breaths
per minute is what we're looking for and
we can read those out as resting
breathing rates going to the next slide
here
those resting breathing rates are then
read out on the
application which is available to
researchers 24/7 and just to prove that
the breathing rates that we're getting
are very reminiscent of what you would
see using more traditional measures in
this case the platysma graph but I've
shown on the far right-hand side here is
data where we put c57 black 6 s as well
as C 3 H H EJ's into a cage these are
multiple readings from multiple animals
we put them in the platysma graph inside
of the cage and we monitored the
breathing rates based on the computer
vision versus what we've monitored in
the FISMA graph and you can see that
there's an extremely high correlation
between the breathing rates in both of
those instances so I believe that the
r-squared here is 0.98 so we're getting
a very accurate measurement I'm using
this camera based system to monitor
resting breathing rate so today I want
to present three use cases and I'm
presenting three different use cases
with different underlying pathologies to
give you a sense for how the resting
breathing rate can predict a lung
function not just in the instance of one
underlying pathology but across multiple
different examples so here we I'll show
you data from an idiopathic pulmonary
fibrosis model so we're using bleomycin
induced here we have a very early
localized acute inflammation response
and then later on we get fibrosis in the
lung and we can show different results
during both that initial acute
inflammation phase as well as the later
fibrosis we're also looking at a
pneumonia model in which we can monitor
this acute systemic inflammatory
response and finally I'll show you data
from a lung metastases model we
specifically use the colon cancer lines
t26 here and we're showing that as you
have increased tumor burden in the lung
it appears to reduce lung volume and we
see changes in breathing rate associated
with that before I get into the first
example I do want to give you an
overview of how we run studies on the
biome platform and the study design
parameters that we use so it's really
important for these studies is that we
use standard study protocols for all
experiments so what you'll see laid out
in all three of these models is that
these are the very common ways that
researchers will run the models we don't
do anything different or unusual and
what's really nice is that the animals
actually remain in the home cage
throughout the whole entire study so no
point apart from when we do the
induction and or if we were to give
treatments or monitor what we call
conventional measures those are the only
times that the animals are actually out
of the home cage otherwise all of the
data that we're showing you here comes
directly through the video cameras and
streamed onto the system so most of
these studies in include two different
phases the first phase is the
acclamation phase and the second phase
is is an induction phase or potentially
we might also add on a treatment each of
these phases have important aspects that
we look at so in the acclimation phase
this is the animal's time and ability to
get used to the biome kind of
environment this is standard this is
what anyone any researcher should be
doing with their animals getting them
used to the vivarium usually that's the
first 1 to 4 days of the study and then
between the last 5 and 7 days we
actually take that as an opportunity to
collect baseline data on all of the
animals I'm
we'll look at in its natural state what
is a mouse's general breathing range our
respiratory rate and how active or
inactive are they and do they show
relatively normal circadian rhythms so
this gets this is important as we get to
the randomization phase so as we move to
randomizing animals into various study
groups so we might take a example a
cohort of 20 animals and break them up
into five groups of four animals or four
groups of five animals what we might do
is look for animals which have abnormal
breathing rates so if all animals have
breathing rates within a small window
and we have one animal that is outside
of two standard deviations we may
actually remove that animal from the
study and that allows us to get more
consistent results and we also make sure
that we that these similar average and
standard deviation of all animals are
the same for the primary outcome
measures that we care most about and so
in this case we focused quite a bit in
most of these studies on breathing rate
although we also did use motion and
sometimes body weight as you'll see and
that happens right before the induction
phase so in the final phase the
induction air treatment phase our goal
is to monitor changes in these primary
endpoints or secondary outcomes from
that baseline state so we can not only
look at group averages but we can also
look at individual animal averages to
know whether or not the induction and/or
treatments is having a positive effect
so when that is an overview let's move
on to the first model so here we'll be
looking at a bleomycin induced lung
fibrosis model this is a model of
idiopathic pulmonary fibrosis so
idiopathic pulmonary fibrosis is a
complex disease
really of unknown etiology there are a
number of different models available for
looking at idiopathic pulmonary fibrosis
but certainly this mouse model of
bleomycin in which the bleomycin is
administered directly into the lungs is
probably the best characterized of all
of the models out there for testing anti
fibrotic compounds there's been a lot of
work done to ensure reproducibility
across labs current best practices for
endpoints and evaluation are looking at
hydroxyproline so this is a measure of
collagen accumulation so this will tell
you the extent of fibrosis across time
and also looking at histologic
assessment of the lungs here there are
some studies which look at lung function
assessments they're considered helpful
but certainly technically challenging
and so it's not common practice to
actually look at this and vivo lung
function in those animals in terms of
thinking about the different phases in
this and this model which has been
extremely well characterized there are
about three different phases so I'll
tell you in our model here we used male
c57 mice we just will show you data from
two groups a control group as well as a
bleomycin group in which we gave three
units per kilogram after a single
administration of bleomycin there's an
initial acute inflammation flip phase
which lasts somewhere between zero and
ten days about three to four days after
the bleomycin administration you start
to see Paula frisson of fibroblasts and
that stage lasts up until about 14 days
and somewhere between 10 and 14 you
start to get some pretty severe fibrosis
so keep that in mind as we start to look
at the results from our study so here
again we're using male C 57 s we gather
during the acclamations phase B we use
automated metrics we look at motion and
breathing rate conventionally the only
measure that we're looking at here is
body weight and just before disease
induction as I talked about we
randomized these animals based on motion
and breathing rate and and eliminated
any animals with pretty significant
increases in breathing rate or decreases
in motion we gave a single
administration of bleomycin and then
we're tracking changes from baseline
across the next 21 days at day 21 we
euthanized all 10 animals and collected
lung weights hydroxyproline and we've
actually sent out tissue for histology
but that hasn't come back yet so I will
not be sharing that data with you today
so just going through some of the
conventional measures to orient you to
the graph and all of the graphs I'll be
showing you here are pretty much the
same along the x-axis you can see the
day of the study with day zero being the
day of induction so the day that we gave
the bleomycin the y-axis has the body
weight so you can see prior to induction
the body weights of the animals are
quite similar following induction the
control animals continue to gain weight
we saw some fluctuations and the animals
induced with bleomycin but none of that
was statistically significant
looking at motion data so this is how
active the animals are we're showing
here average night time motion data
importantly we look at night time motion
because this is the when the animals are
most active and we find it's most
indicative of any kind of an animal
feeling bad or in the case of more CNS
oriented diseases changes and overall
motor function again you can see prior
to the dotted line where we gave the
bleomycin overall motion between the
groups is quite similar after that
actually the groups remain fairly
similar and so there is no significant
difference between the bleomycin induced
and the control animals importantly this
appears to be suggestive that there was
a minimal kind of systemic effect of the
bleomycin so certainly if you were to
give bleomycin by an IP injection or
another method you could imagine that
the animal would have a fairly
significant response so this was quite
nice and that it really indicated to us
that we were pretty much affecting the
lungs only and not more broadly moving
on to breathing rate so here you can see
again prior to bleomycin induction the
breathing rates between all animals were
extremely consistent right around 190
breaths per minute
once we administered the bleomycin again
at that dotted line the animals with
bleomycin showed a very significant drop
in breathing rates down to almost 120
breaths per minute on average and that
was the initial response that we saw
that at days two
and three was that significant drop and
then by about days nine or so we saw a
significant increase in breathing rate
in these animals which then persisted
for quite some time so again now we're
seeing a short-term decrease in motion
which may be associated with that
initial inflammation and a longer-term
increase in breathing rate which we
associate with more of the fibrosis and
just to give you a sense for whether or
not this is associated with more of the
biochemical indices commonly looked at
it in the bleomycin model here we're
showing you lung weight to body weight
ratios so here the animals in blue are
those that receive the bleomycin versus
those in gray received the control you
can see a significant increase in lung
wait and remember this is again at day
21 and then on the right you can see
lung hydroxyproline spread out and again
we see a significant increase in
hydroxyproline content in the bleomycin
animals compared to the control which
would suggest that we do have increased
a collagen content and fibrosis so the
question now becomes those increases in
breathing rate are they well correlated
to either of these indices and in fact
they are so on this slide again I'm
showing you the lung weight to body
weight ratio which you saw on the prior
slide and I'm also showing you the
correlation now between lung weight and
the breathing rate ratio so here we're
looking at the average breathing rate
resting breathing rate on the last day
of the study so this is helps you
correlate the breathing rate at the time
of you
Venetia to the lung weight at the time
of euthanasia and here we see a very
significant correlation with an
r-squared of somewhere around 0.8 9
suggesting that as breathing rate
increases the lung weight also increases
perhaps more importantly we see a
similar correlation when you look at
lung collagen content so again on the
Left I'm showing you the same data from
before showing the increased
hydroxyproline and the bleomycin animals
and on the right I'm now showing you the
breathing rate to hydroxyproline content
and you can see a fairly nice
correlation with an r-squared of 0.65
where again increases in hydroxyproline
content or fibrosis are associated with
increases in breathing rate so the
conclusions from this study that we draw
is that we have fairly nice signal
specificity so in this case we're seeing
a nice signal in the breathing rate
which occurs around the time of expected
onset of fibrosis but we're not seeing a
more systemic response ie we're not
seeing any change in motion in addition
as I just showed you in the last two
slides in both cases are both measures
at day 21 we see that breathing rate is
highly correlated to what individuals or
researchers consider the gold standard
which is collagen content as well as
overall long wait and we'll continue to
look to see whether we see similar
correlations with histology is that data
comes in but I did not say and what's
also important is we actually think that
the signal is fairly
we can show data that the signal is
quite strong so doing a priori power
analysis so looking back at the study
remember we have ends of five in each of
these groups we discovered that in order
to be able to tell a significant
difference between the control and the
bleomycin induced animals retrospective
power analysis would suggest that we
would need ends up three per group
versus looking at hydroxyproline content
which is just a more varied assay you
would need some somewhere around ends of
13 which was actually quite in quite
interesting because ends of 13 or 10 to
13 are what is most commonly used in in
studies so what this would suggest is
that you can actually use fewer animals
on in these studies if you used
breathing rate as one of your primary
endpoints so the second model that we
looked at is an acute pneumonia model so
here we're looking we're using bacterial
Pseudomonas aeruginosa which is one of
the most common causes of pneumonia so
look at lung infection so current best
practice endpoints for evaluation are
removing lungs and actually doing CFU
counts so how much bacteria is in the
lung doing histologic assessment of the
lung as well as monitoring systemic
cytokine responses to look at overall
response to the Pseudomonas in this case
lung function assessment is very rarely
done there are only a few papers which
actually look at lung function but in
the cases where it has been looked at
the values again correspond quite well
with standard endpoints so wood suggests
that if you had an easy way of
monitoring lung
function it could be quite suggestive in
this model so looking at our
experimental design here we use male
bouncy mice that were between nine and
ten weeks of age and much like that last
group we have a control showing you data
from a control group with an end of five
and a group with the state of Mona's
original so again with an end of five we
do a standard seven-day acclimation
period the only addition here is we're
looking at two conventional measures so
body weight and body temperature but
you've both been shown to correlate
nicely with or be useful measures for
looking at pneumonia in these animals
and we're randomizing again on breathing
rate and on motion so to induce the
disease we do a single administration of
the Pseudomonas aeruginosa
we gave the animals five times ten to
the sorry five point five times ten to
the seventh CFU or saline and we did
that through a nasal and injection or
induction where we did a single drop to
the nose and then had the animals inhale
the state of bonus and then we tracked
changes from baseline again looking at
the conventional measures body weight
and body temperature for two days as
well as some of the automated metrics
from the biome platform motion and
breathing rate so looking at
conventional monitoring of animal health
we see typical signs of illness in these
animals so here we're looking at body
weight and body temperature again so we
do daily body weight measurements again
you can see that the Pseudomonas
blue prior to induction at day zero body
weights are not statistically different
between the groups but then by a day one
day in two days afterwards you see
significant drops in body weight in
those animals that receive the student
bonus original we also see a very
consistent drop in body temperature so
again the dotted line is when the
animals received Pseudomonas and both
two and seven hours post induction we
see a significant drop in body
temperature but by 24 hours the animals
are back to baseline so in both these
cases we see signs of illness in the
case of body temperature we see a
transient reduction in body temperature
which is associated again with this
inflammatory response looking at
cytokine levels this is a fairly busy
graph but please take a few moments to
look and see we see significant
increases in TNF alpha as would be
expected significant increases in Aisle
10 kc g ro IL 6 as well as il-1 beta and
INF gamma and this is a profile which is
very risk reflective of what would
normally be seen in this model and again
these data were taken at 48 hours post
induction
now looking at biometrics here is a
graph showing motion data across time
where the dark bars represent night time
and the white bars represent daytime you
can see prior to induction which is the
dotted line and just before the end of
the graph you can see very nice
circadian rhythms and the animals with
much more nighttime activity compared to
the daytime activity however post
induction with the Pseudomonas there is
a significant drop in nighttime activity
so you can see that the nighttime
activity drops about 8 hours after
induction and it actually remains low
through all through that first night as
well as during the second night again
suggestive now that we're seeing a more
systemic inflammatory response when we
look at breathing rate prior to the
induction we have very similar breathing
rates so again right around 190 average
breaths per minute but within four hours
or so a sorry eight hours post induction
we see a significant increase in
breathing rate which persists all the
way through that first night and into
the second night so this response lasts
for upwards of thirty six to forty hours
so next question is are these increases
in breathing rate a so correlated with
the changes that we see in the cytokine
data and the answer to that question is
absolutely so here we're just showing a
few examples il-6 il-10 and KC G ro
we are showing the breathing rate is now
on the x-axis and the level of the
cytokine is on the y-axis and you can
see a nice correlation with lower
breathing rates are associated with
lower levels of these cytokines whereas
higher breathing rates are associated
with higher levels suggesting that as
you see an increase in this inflammatory
response you see increases in breathing
rate we've also shown this with
decreases in motion but that we're just
not showing that data here so
conclusions we draw from this study is
that we're getting nice signal
specificity again so again there's a
clear signal both associated with
increased breathing rate as well as with
a decreased motion now so this is in
contrast to what we saw with the
bleomycin induced with the bleomycin
induced model and then that persists
longer than more typical measures of
these inflammatory response in essence
the body temperature and then again
breathing rate is now correlated to the
cytokine levels so what one could
hypothesize is that you could monitor
breathing rate and get a fairly nice
idea of what an the underlying extent of
the inflammatory response is and while
I've not shown the data here I have
shown it in Prior presentations and
we're doing additional work here it does
seem that this is consistent across a
number of different models in which
there's a broader inflammatory response
and so we've seen nice correlations
between breathing rate motion and
cytokines in an LPS Challenge model as
well as an acute liver toxicity model of
which there is data out and I'd be happy
to share that data with anyone who's
interested
again we also see a nice signal strength
here so looking at retrospective power
analysis it suggests that being using
breathing rates we would need ends of
four in order to be able to
statistically distinguish animals that
had gotten the Pseudomonas versus not
with even ends of three promotion but
that you would need larger ends on the
order of five to six to detect some of
these larger changes in cytokine levels
so it does suggest that the signal is a
bit stronger than some of the
conventional standard metrics that have
been used okay now for our last model
will be looking or we looked at a lung
metastases model using the CT 26 colon
carcinoma line so metastasis is the
spread of cancer to the non-original
areas so in this case colon cancer
spreading to the lungs and it's a
significant problem that requires
improved treatment options so in this
case in this model we injected tumor
cells from the CT 26 line directly into
the systemic circulation and these are
some of the most common models for
studying lung lung metastasis so CT 26
is just one line there are about 10 to
15 lines that researchers can use to
study metastasis current best practices
for endpoints in this case are imaging
and so if the cell line is also includes
blonde luminescent signal you could look
at that as well as in MRI or potentially
using a PET scan to look at the location
and the extent of tumor burden in the
animal this case will focus mainly on
looking at Grossmont necropsy and
histology so looking at the extent of
tumor burden in the lungs of the animals
using a more using a terminal procedure
the model here oh is this in generic
model so we used male bouncy mice that
were seven to eight weeks the vault age
we actually looked at five different
groups in this model so we used a
control IV injection we gave two
different concentrations of cells a 1
times 10 to the 4 and a 1 times 10 to
the 5th both via IV injection and to
show that it really is tumor burden in
the lung and not associated with the
animals having these cells injected more
broadly we also did a subcutaneous flank
injection so we have a control group
where we did a subcutaneous injection of
saline and then a 2 times 10 to the 6 of
the CT 26 cells injected as always we
acclimated the animals for seven days
and then we gave either that single IV
or subcutaneous injection of a CT 26 or
a control and we tracked changes from
baseline here we used bodyweight is the
only conventional measure as well as
changes in motion and breathing rate and
to look at tumor progression we
euthanized two different groups of
animals one at day 21 and then one at
day 28 post induction to look at the
extent of tumor formation in the lung as
well as in the subcutaneous group we
looked at the size of the tumor on the
flank looking at body weight in all of
the grafts on this in this section I'll
show you the IV and the subcutaneous
tumor groups graphed separately so here
you can see that in the lung metastasis
model prior to induction body weights
are very similar and they remain
very similar post induction until about
days 24 post induction where we start to
see a very significant decrease in the
animals that received the high dose but
not the low dose of the CT 26 cells so
those animals in the gray are those that
received the saline injection the light
blue are the low dose of cells and the
dark blue are the high dose of cells in
the case of the sub subcutaneous tumor
group we actually see increases in body
weight and the animals that receive the
subcutaneous tumor this makes sense
because the tumor weighs something and
therefore those animals are getting
heavier we start to see changes around
20 days after the injection and it
becomes more statistically significant
the farther out you go the next question
was whether or not we actually saw
metastases in the lungs so here I'm
showing you control animals in the first
column the second column are those
animals that received the IV injection
the third column are those animals that
received the subcutaneous injections so
those are the injection on the flank the
top row my apologies that that's not
labeled our our example lungs from day
21 and the bottom row our example lungs
from day 28 what you can see in the
control animals is that we really see no
metastases we also see none in the
subcutaneous tumor group at either the
21 or the 28 days and then in the IV
group we see very few in this example
perhaps one metastasis that one nodule
at day 21 but by 28 you can see the
lungs are are filled
with these tumor nodules we went on to
quantify those so here I'm showing you
nodule count on the left so here we
filled or we filled the lungs with India
ink to allow the nodules to stand out a
little bit more and what I've graphed
are the number of nodules both of the
early and the late time points for each
of the conditions so what you can see in
the IV load low-dose cell line we see
very few nodules it's on the order I
believe of three to four on average for
either for both below sorry the early as
well as the late time point in contrast
for the animals that receive the high
cell count we can see a significant
increase both at the 21-day time point
as well as at the 28-day time point with
a significant increase between the 21
and the 28-day time count time points in
contrast to what we see in the IV saline
injected animals where we see no nodules
at all on the Left are sorry on the
right just to show you tumor size we
actually did conduct caliper
measurements on the animals with the
subcutaneous tumors and there you can
just see that in comparison to the
control animals which are in gray and
had no tumors that we did see
significant increases in tumor size or
we did see significant tumor size in
those subcutaneous tumor injected
animals so now looking at the via
metrics we saw significant changes in
motion but only in the lung metastasis
group so on the the left
again we see the lung metastases group
and prior to injection of the tumor
cells motion was very similar across all
groups very similar to the body weight
we see no real change in motion until
about day 23 after injection at which
point we see a significant decrease in
the motion in just a high cell group in
comparison there is no significant
difference in the animals that received
the one times 10 to the fourth cells
looking at the subcutaneous tumors there
was no change in motion at all in those
groups both groups showed similar motion
profiles now we're looking at breathing
rate and again similar to what we saw in
motion we only see significant changes
in breathing rate and those animals
which had tumors in the lung so the lung
metastasis grew so prior to injection of
the tumor cells you can see that the
average breathing rate is somewhere
around 180 breaths per minute this is
very similar across all of the studies
in fact in those first twenty or so days
we see no real significant change
although perhaps the low cell group has
a few days in which they have
significantly higher breathing rates but
once you get out to the point where we
start to see tumor nodule growth in the
lungs those animals that received the
high number of cells have a very
significant increase in breathing rate
in comparison to the animals which
should had the low group the low cell
number which showed an intermediate
increase in breathing rate all of that
compared to the control animals whose
breathing rates really did not change
across the course of the 28-day study so
here we can see a dose-dependent
increase in breathing rate in these lung
metastasis groups in comparison again
remember the goal of the subcutaneous
tumor group was to show that changes in
breathing and/or emotion were not
associated with just having the cells in
the animal's body again you can see that
in this group we see no significant
difference in breathing rate in these
animals across the course of the 28-day
study so the next question is it seems
convenient that we see increases in
breathing rate in those animals with the
high nodule count versus the low are
those significantly correlated so here
what we're showing you our average
breathing rate again this is at the
terminal day so we're looking at only
breathing rates at the time where we can
actually have a good correlation with
lung tumor nodule account and we're
comparing that to lung tumor nodules and
you can see again a significant
correlation here between breathing rate
and lung tumor nodule account with an
r-squared of somewhere around 0.65 or 66
suggesting that as the tumor as the lung
becomes more burden with two tumors it
becomes more challenging potentially for
that animal to breathe and breathing
rates are now going up so from the lung
metastases model again we feel that we
are getting signal specificity here so
we have a clearer signal again in motion
and improving rate for those animals
that have lung metastases but we're not
seeing a signal in the mice with
subcutaneous tumors only the deep what's
interesting is that decrease in motion
which I showed you perceives it's
significant decrease in body weight
which would suggest that it's a little
bit more sensitive than body weight for
looking at overall animal health in the
case of animals with one metastasis and
finally that again breathing rate is
highly correlated to the number of tumor
nodules in the lung so you can imagine
with additional tumor nodules you could
imagine that breathing rate may continue
to go up and that this is potentially a
very sensitive way and to be able to
monitor or to get a sense of tumor
burden in animals without having to
euthanize them at specific time points
and or do potentially more invasive
monitoring of animals using PET scan or
MRI so summarizing the conclusions from
all of the use cases here the overall
question that we asked was can automated
monitoring arresting breathing rate
actually predict a lung function in
these models I've showed you three
different or data from three different
models one from an idiopathic pulmonary
fibrosis model a pneumonia model and a
lung metastases model and again we
looked at each of these models because
you can imagine a different underlying
cause for each and we wanted to see how
consistent it is across each of these
different kind of mechanisms we showed
increased breathing rates with fibrosis
that correlate to collagen content in
the idiopathic pulmonary fibrosis model
we showed increased breathing rates and
decreased motion associated with
systemic inflammation and that that
breathing rate correlated with cytokine
drivers of the immune response in the
pneumonia model and finally we showed
that breathing rates increased with
increased tumor burden but only in those
animals with lung metastases and that
those breathing rates correlate with a
number of nodules in the lung in
that CT 26 colon cancer metastases model
so thinking about the conclusions from
these studies we go back to the question
that we asked at the beginning of this
presentation so remember the question
was what bhisma graph and forced
oscillation are using the flex event is
there potentially another way of
monitoring lung function by using
resting breathing rate in this automated
system so we asked the question where
the results were consistent and do they
recapitulate underlying biology and/or
pathology and the animals and what we
hope we've shown you today are giving
you a taste for today is that the
answers to those questions are probably
yes
so what we're showing you here is that
using an automated homepage monitoring
system where in essence all you have to
do is run your study in your typical way
buying being able to measure resting
breathing rate in these animals we're
measuring in essence a correlation of
lung function with in freely moving
animals that are truly in their natural
state so while the platysma graph is
more in their natural state you still
have animals which are constrained and
may show stress responses in comparison
to animals that are in their home caged
environment and we actually think that
because they are in their natural state
and they're not stressed out and they're
not being interacted with by humans that
this is actually why we're getting far
more conclusive results i'm using the
home cage system versus a plethora graph
as an example we also show that we can
do continuous monitoring which allows
for kinetic assessment so rather than
taking the animals out and doing many
different time points across in the case
of plethysmograph or perhaps having
to have many different groups in the
case of the flexi vent system if it is a
terminal procedure by monitoring 24/7
you can actually see the increase in
breathing rate kind of an animal by
animal basis to be able to get an
assessment from each animal about
potentially how sick what that is
systemic inflammatory responses tumor
burning etc because we know that not
every one of these models follows a kind
of perfect kinetic path so overall we
think that this is potentially a new way
in which you can actually monitor lung
function across a number of these lung
disease models to get a fast easy and
fairly accurate assessment of underlying
biology and with that I open it up to
any questions and thank you for taking
the time to listen today thank you dr.
Chaffetz for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the answer question
box located on the far left of your
screen we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for so let's
get started
our first question is and what other
types of therapeutic areas or disease
models do you think that breathing rates
would provide additional insight into
disease that's a great question so I
alluded in the presentation to you one
area where we found breathing rate to be
quite informative and that's in any form
of systemic inflammatory response so we
looked across a number of different
responses and seen changes in breathing
rate associated with the LPS induction
ma our challenge model as an example
acute liver talks
city we've also seen changes in
breathing rate in a number of models in
which individuals would not necessarily
expect to or think about breathing as
being a key primary outcome measure so
we've seen it in a number of models of
CNS and neurological disorders as well
um so I I think the answer to your
question is it's probably broad and we
could possibly see it across a number of
different therapeutic areas we generally
take the approach of the platform reads
it out on all models and therefore we
should be able to get a sense across
models of which ones might be
potentially most interesting our next
question is does this system increase
your study power again a great question
so I tried to go through quite a bit of
across the presentation but we are
seeing that in many instances being able
to monitor these metrics basically 24/7
so we're getting I didn't actually go
into this in the actual presentation but
we get somewhere around the two million
data points for emotion and we're
getting somewhere
much fewer in the way of breathing rate
points just because of the fact that we
have to measure resting breathing rate
but because we're getting them both the
day and night we actually see that we
can use that we can use fewer animals
potentially in order to get very high
power I think I showed you in the
bleomycin model that we would need and
the three or four in order to be able to
Cystic distinguish the groups versus
ends of 13 with more traditional
measures so again you know it'll depend
on a study by studying a model by model
basis but in general we're finding that
being able to use these
continuous measures we do get increased
study power now Laura this is a
three-part question interesting data
thank you if I wanted to run a study on
this platform what are my options do you
sell the system and do you collaborate
to develop new models so the answer to
your question is yes and yes so we've
just recently started to sell a
protection version of our system and
have actually just recently done a few
installs so it is available for those
individuals who want to go that route
we're also very interested in
collaborating with groups of individuals
who have models they think would be
highly conducive to the volume platform
so we work with a number of academic
groups as well as pharma biotechs to
develop models and to identify the best
metrics and additional metrics that they
could potentially use so you know feel
free to reach out to us on either of
those if you're interested in actually
working with or running your models on
our platform and it looks like we have
time for one more question you mentioned
these are resting breathing rates what
is the frequency of breathing rate Rhett
measurements you get a great question
again so we've actually looked one of
the fun parts about our system is that
we can look at all of the data that
we've collected over the last actually
four years so we've looked at all
animals rats mice and whatnot we find
that on average we get about 150 to 200
data points or mice the majority of
those actually occur during the day when
the animals are asleep because they tend
to be at rest more in rats that number
is actually a bit higher
so we get somewhere although I didn't
talk about any rats today but we get
somewhere around 300 or so breathing
rate points over the course of a day so
you can imagine depending upon the
length of your study how many data
points that might be before we go I'd
like to thank the audience for joining
us today and for their interesting
questions questions we did not have time
for today and those submitted during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
the speaker via the contact information
you provided at the time of the
registration we would like to thank
laberd's and our sponsor vayam for
underwriting today's educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on-demand
through December of 2018 labyrinth will
alert via email when it's available for
replay we encourage you to share that
email with your colleagues who may have
missed today's live event until next
time goodbye